okay
well uh welcome back to another problem
session it's great to see everybody
smiling faces again
uh uh right so today we're going to
continue our discussion of graph theory
problems uh this time focusing on
well a little bit of this a little bit
of that some shortest path problems all
pairs shortest path
uh and then a modification of the
dijkstra algorithm to uh
finishes off for the day um so
as always we'll go through our problem
session problems in order for no reason
other than that's the way they were
presented to me
and i think roughly isomorphic to how
most of the homeworks in this class go
anyway
uh but in any event uh let's get started
here
so uh in in uh problem session problem
7-1 here as always our first problem is
sort of a
warm-up to make sure that we understand
all these sort of definitions techniques
that we use in 6.06
today we're going to go over dijkstra's
algorithm
so if you all recall dicer's algorithm
is a technique for computing
shortest path from a single source to
your rest of your graph
there's about a million different ways
to explain understand uh
dijkstra's algorithm so i'll undoubtedly
revert upon the one that i remember
which is probably not the one that jason
just covered in lecture but we'll make
it work and of course if there are any
questions we'll
we'll address those along the way here
uh i'm going to switch to a piece of
chalk that
isn't an eighth of an inch and get
started
uh right so in problem uh 1a of our
homework here we were asked to run
dicer's algorithm
from uh vertex s here
by the way just sort of a standard
terminology and graph theory that i
think we'll see a lot in the homework
is we typically use s for the sort of
starting point
of a path or sometimes the source if
we're talking about network flows but i
don't think we do those in this class
uh and then t is usually the destination
um
yt you might ask because it's the letter
after s
uh right so uh our first uh task here
is to compute the single source shortest
path from
s to everything else in our graph
initially this looks painful uh but it's
not
um so you're gonna forgive me i'm gonna
write a sort of shorthand version
of dijkstra's algorithm because i'm
talking to you as i solve this problem
which of course would be much more
annoying for you guys to do uh on paper
uh but that's life in the city uh so so
so there that's my
what in the words of britney spears it's
my prerogative as your instructor here
okay so in dijkstra's algorithm what do
we do we initially label
all of our vertices as having distance
infinity to the source
or and we insert them into our priority
queue
except for one vertex which of course is
our source vertex
uh and he or she has vert has distance
zero for an obvious reason which is that
if my path starts at the source
it has distance zero to the source so as
our shorthand
was uh do i want to use red yes of
course i do
uh yeah but it's this fat chalk man
um okay zero i can make this work
okay so uh our our convention for today
is going to be if a vertex does not have
a label on it it is distance infinity
okay uh so what does dijkstra's
algorithm do
uh dice's algorithm grabs the closest
vertex that i haven't yet processed
uh and closest in terms of the distance
value that i've stored at that vertex
and then updates all of its neighbors
using sort of a triangle inequality
uh style construction so let's see what
that looks like so
so far everything is distance infinity
away except for one vertex which is
vertex
s which is distance zero so obviously
that should be our first iteration
of dijkstra's algorithm and now what
vertex s is going to do is look at all
of s's neighbors
and update them using the triangle
inequality and if they're closer by
having a path
through s to the neighbor then i update
the distance
and if it's not then i don't uh in this
case everything is infinity
so it's pretty clear that i should route
my path through s because
any distance less than infinity is
smaller than infinity
uh so in particular notice that there's
an edge of length eight
from s to a so now rather than being
distance infinity away
i can see that uh vertex a is really
distance eight away oh this truck gives
me shiv
uh similarly here there's an edge of
length seven
uh and i believe that's all of the edges
out of s so we're good
and now the kind of nice thing about the
way dijkstra's algorithm works
um which i guess was a little bit
implicit in the construction we saw
yesterday but but that's okay
is that once i visit a vertex i never i
never touch it again
right it gets frozen in time uh in
in distance i suppose uh but in any
event well that means i'm gonna put a
little box around it
meaning i'm done with this guy he's no
longer in my queue
okay hopefully our pictorial system
makes some sense here
again on your homework problem you
actually have to write this stuff out
and i'm sorry that sucks
uh but i don't have to because i'm
talking to you all today okay
so remember dijkstra's algorithm we're
going to look at our list of vertices we
haven't seen yet so that's everything
except for s
find the one that's closest and process
that one next so in this case that's the
seven here
uh okay so let's take a look what are
the neighbors of seven well i've got
s uh and that's oh and d
here okay so first of all let's take a
look at s
obviously if i have a path that goes
through c
back through this vertical edge to s
that path have length eight right seven
plus one
eight is bigger than zero so i do not
update s
but we actually already knew that
because s was frozen here so i didn't
even have to look at that edge i could
have removed
it if i wanted to uh okay
but there's another edge coming out of c
which is pointing toward d
that has length 4. 7 plus 4 is wait for
it
11 and that's less than infinity so i
update
these distance to 11 and i don't think
i've managed to make a mistake
yet okay so now we've looked at all the
edges out of c
and c is frozen and we move on
okay next uh let's see among our
vertices we have infinity eight and
eleven
so the smallest of those three numbers
is eight and we're gonna update all the
neighbors of the eight
uh which thankfully although this graph
looks big uh
they had some mercy on your your section
of structure today and really there
aren't that many edges so this isn't too
hard to uh process
but here's the thing uh there's an edge
of length zero from a to d
here i can get to the a in eight units
so i can also get to the d and 8 units
by traversing that edge 8 is less than
11.
that's good news do i want to erase it
or scratch it out what's going to be
better
i'll scratch it up just to be missed
okay so now d is a distance eight
from uh vertex s and i believe that's
all the edges out of a
so a is set okay
this is fun or what so now we look at
all the edges out of well oh sorry
we step back and we look at all of our
uh vertices we find the closest one
that's d now we've got to update all of
these neighbors
so uh thankfully all the remaining
vertices have distance infinity
uh so what do we know there's an edge of
length one here so i get a nine
there's an edge of length two so i get a
ten
um and i believe those are all the
outgoing edges from d
and now d set i'm gonna start moving
faster because this is hella boring
uh okay now the next closest uh edge is
the nine
uh notice that the nine only or rather b
i suppose is the vertex
which is currently at distance nine uh
it only has one neighbor that hasn't yet
been processed
which is e uh so we know that that's
nine to eleven twelve
distance away i'm gonna check my scrap
paper and make sure i haven't made any
mistakes yet
seven eight cool
okay so now our next closest vertex is
vertex
h which is distance 10. and aha
if i traverse the edge upward from h to
e
i can get a path of length 11 and 11
according to most mathematicians is less
than 12
and hence we should update the value
here
uh in addition to that there is an edge
of length 2 out of h
pointing into g 10 plus 2 is 12.
and i believe that's it
getting there okay so the next closest
vertex is e e has no outgoing edges so
e is all set uh
after that we've got g g has an outgoing
edge of length one
into d twelve plus one's thirteen which
is less is
larger than eight so we don't update uh
and similarly twelve plus zero
is bigger than seven so we don't update
but again the edges that point into
vertices that we've already processed we
really don't have to even consider
uh just by the way that dijkstra's
algorithm works notice that if there
were a negative weight edge we're going
to come back to
then that assumption will be problematic
so the takeaway here
is that this guy's frozen in stone and
now
notice that our queue is actually empty
yeah so depending on how we set up our
or well it's not empty
um but it only contains one vertex and
it's at l uh distance infinity
infinity plus zero is still infinity
uh so that's this guy's uh distance here
and now we're now our q is empty sorry
okay so i believe
i managed to do that right excellent so
the problem asks for two things that ask
for the single source
uh shortest path distance it also asks
for the traversal order which i forgot
to do while i was doing this problem but
you could retrace it pretty easily
okay so uh that's part a then in part b
they say change the weight of the edge
from g
to c to minus six
so we have g to c and now
instead of zero we're gonna make it
minus six and the question
is if i ran dijkstra's algorithm
essentially what would break
and i think it's pretty easy to eyeball
remember that ge was essentially the
last interesting vertex that we touched
in our algorithm here
the only one that we looked at was was f
and so this outgoing edge from g
actually wouldn't even be seen by
dijkstra's algorithm thankfully until
we've touched all these other vertices
in an identical fashion to our previous
traversal uh and then we finally get to
g
and now what's going to happen well if i
have this edge of length negative 6
what's 12 minus 6 that's 6.
and notice that that's less than
[Music]
7 which is the the label of vertex c
but that breaks our assumption which is
that as soon as i visit a vertex i never
have to touch it again right because now
i've identified a path through g back to
c that has a smaller distance
than the path that c had when it was
visited in the queue
so somehow spiritually i should add c
back to the q but that's against the
rules
and daishi's algorithm right so like for
instance if i did that
i would have to convince myself that the
runtime doesn't explode
uh and this algorithm terminates right
which could be a problem if you have a
negative weight cycle
thankfully we have algorithms for
detecting negative weight cycles but
that's a different matter
okay so i think this is pretty
straightforward it's just essentially
asking you to
walk through dicer's algorithm make sure
you understand what's going on
any uh questions about that one cool i
think it's one of the easier uh
problem sessions so then we'll finish
early except i always say that and then
i talk too much
i'm sorry not sorry
okay so uh right so in problem 7-2
this is an extension of a problem that
we considered i believe
two problem sessions ago uh and it looks
something like this
i'm gonna go back into my notes so
remember in two problem sessions ago we
defined the radius of a graph
for an unweighted graph we came up with
an algorithm for computing it and
approximating it all that good stuff
uh now in this problem uh we're going to
do basically the same thing
but now we're on a weighted graph yeah
so in particular we're going to define a
quantity
this is problem two called weighted
eccentricity
uh which is associated to a vertex in a
weighted graph
and it looks like this so the weighted
eccentricity associated to vertex
u is equal to the max
over all vertices in my graph of the
shortest path distance from u to that
vertex
again hopefully our audience will catch
if i accidentally swap the argument to
shortest path because i'm used to
thinking of that as symmetric but
it's not uh because our graphs are
directed
um actually in this problem i don't
think the graph is directed so
forget it's directed okay good yeah then
good i'll try to be accurate
okay and just like the problem we had uh
two problem sessions ago
um so the eccentricities associated with
the vertex is sort of like the distance
to the farthest away thing
in my graph and now the radius of my
graph tries to find the most
central vertex which is the minimizer
of weighted eccentricity and we call
that the weighted radius
and so the rated the weight that's the
tough one
the weighted radius
is a measurement which is associated not
with the vertex but rather with the
graph
and it's equal to the min over all
possible vertices u of the weighted
eccentricity of u
okay and so the problem here is that
we're given a weighted directed graph
with no negative weight cycle
so it may have negative weights but they
can't have a negative cycle
and the question oh i touched my face uh
the question is what is the
can i find uh the radius of my graph
in time that looks like or
mod v cubed
okay now if you recall from our previous
problem session when we considered
computing the radius of a graph
what did we do well we tried to come up
with a
a clever algorithm and then we realized
that that was actually kind of
unnecessary that it turned out that the
kind of brain dead thing where you just
look at the definitions and just make it
work uh was actually good enough
uh and that actually turns out to be the
case here right this is a good reminder
for us all that
before we go crazy you know 606 is a fun
algorithms class we get to learn about
cute you know references to tv shows and
all that um
before we go crazy with that of course
if there's an obvious algorithm
staring us in the face to solve a given
algorithms problem
we should try that first before we try
something more clever
and indeed in this case uh that works
so what are the sort of ingredients that
we need to compute the radius well the
radius is the minimum eccentricity
so what would be the smartest or the
simplest thing to do rather would be
compute the
eccentricity for every vertex and take
the smallest
how do i compute the ethnicity for every
vertex well i have to have the max
distance uh away from that vertex
so what would be a simple thing to do
would be to compute distances between
all the possible vertices
and conveniently in lecture in some day
or another i'm a little confused about
the time
ordering of this class because of the
way we're filming it
uh we have covered an algorithm that
computes the distance between every pair
of vertices
and that's called johnson's algorithm
yeah so
if we were to do a totally brain dead
version
of solving this problem maybe for
convenience the first thing we do is
compute delta uv for every possible uv
pair
and because our graph doesn't have a
negative weight cycle we can do that
with johnson's algorithm yeah so step
one
is to use johnson's algorithm
uh for all pairs
shortest path and i'll refer you guys to
the lecture for how to do that
um but the important thing is the
runtime of this step of our algorithm
so johnson's algorithm generically
speaking has
v e
plus v squared log
v hopefully i got that right uh runtime
and uh what do we know about our problem
well i believe we're given that the
graph is connected
um and so one thing that we can do is
notice that e is upper bounded by v
squared i guess even if it's not
connected i'm sorry that's a dumb thing
to say
just generically speaking our graph is
is simple so we know that e
at most is i guess two v squared
which means that this term is upper
bounded by v cubed right
so we have v cubed plus order v squared
log v
so at the end of the day the first term
wins and we have this
is v cubed time notice that we're given
that budget in the statement of our
problem so
this is perfectly fine in other words
this is a long-winded way of saying it's
kosher to compute all pairs shortest
path
in the constraints of our problem here
so that's convenient because now in step
two well
maybe now we just keep you know we
follow we do the the toucan sam approach
again we follow our noses
and well now that we have our pairwise
distances
we can now compute the eccentricity for
every vertex
for all you just directly
of course in your homework you should
write out what that means but here
directly just means that for every u i
loop over every v
and i take whatever value is biggest so
notice that i have
two loops one over u one over v so this
is
order mod v squared time
so already the first term is is
dominating here so that's that's a good
thing
i guess uh and then finally
we have to take the smallest
eccentricity of uh
and a u which just requires one more
photo so this time i i for loop over
this array
and i just take the smallest value right
so this is just one for loop so that
takes order
v time and then we're done right so
that's uh our technique for computing
the radius
and notice that all i did was translate
the definition into an algorithm i
didn't do
anything smart in this problem at all uh
and then we should really quickly double
check our run time so step one takes v
cube time step two takes b squared time
step three takes v time
so we add them all together and of
course the v cubed wins uh and that
is what was given in our our problem as
our budget
okay so i think the first two problems
in this uh this this problem session are
fairly straightforward are there
any questions so far i'm talking fast
cool all right so now we're going to
move on to problem three
involving atmos caverdin uh
who is uh you know probably playing the
what the the gunger games hunger games
that was close
um sorry under uh whatever
uh you get the point yep
so before i get carried away trying to
read jason's uh
jokes here um what's going on in this
problem so
this is problem three there's an
underground sewer network
i suppose we also could have written
this problem about mit right there's all
kinds of crazy underground tunnels here
i remember when i was looking at mit as
a potential undergrad
they had us like schlepping around the
tunnels and i thought they were very
dirty and i didn't get the point so i
went to stanford but
uh in any event um right so uh what i'm
given is a map
and uh this thing has uh n
bi-directional
pipes
i'm not going to write it down but the
problem tells you that they're all
connected they make a
like you can get from your source to
your target moving through the pipes
um and uh
right there and they're connected at
junctions
uh but uh at every junction there's less
than or equal to four things that come
together
so just like in our last problem session
every time you see a phrase like that
it's like screaming out there's a degree
bound
uh hiding inside of your graph uh and
moreover
every junction is reachable from every
other junction i believe
okay in addition to this
we're given a positive integer
length
for each pipe
um so it's starting to smell like a
shortest path problem but is it
that's our question uh but
just to make things a little bit worse
atnes
coverdean here is trying to escape
through the pipes
and she doesn't want to be detected and
in particular
there exists junctions
with uh motion sensors
and apparently atnes's intel is pretty
good here and she knows which
of the junctions in her pipe network uh
actually have
motion sensor sensors that um
that can detect people moving around
okay
um now what this problem is asking her
to do
is to say like maybe apparently she
knows where the motion sensors are but
maybe she doesn't know if they're like
you know
what kind of brand they are you know is
it a microsoft sensor or a
apple sensor or something and of course
the sensors have different ranges
right so so atnes coverdeen here she
wants to be as conservative
as possible when she traverses this pipe
network
in particular what we're looking for
what she wants
is in n log n time here
find the path
that maximizes the distance to the
sensors
so hopefully this problem makes sense so
you've got some you know
grid graph well not necessarily a grid
graph but there's a bunch of vertices of
valence
for maybe something like that you know
it makes sense it's you know she's
living in a city somewhere
and she has some source that she's
starting at some destination she wants
to go
and then a few of these vertices
are marked as having motion sensors at
them
and rather than like giving you a radius
or something like that instead what
we're saying
is that she wants to go from the source
to the target she's willing to walk a
long distance the length of the path
doesn't matter
what matters is that she never wants to
get closer to
any motion sensor maybe there's a second
one like here
then she has to okay so like in this
case i guess if i were to eyeball it
looks like you can't do better than one
edge right so she would go
like that uh and of course uh in an
extreme scenario it might be the case
that like there's a sensor in every
junction in which case she's uh
host um but we'd like to let her know
that before she
uh embarks upon her journey here okay so
does our problem make enough sense
excellent um okay
so right so unfortunately for us
this is a again it doesn't look like a
shortest path problem and the reason is
because you know it's
it's not uh but rather uh it's
sort of a reachability problem in
disguise and and let's think about what
i mean here
so um right so there's an obvious graph
here
we'll call it g out of a lack of
creativity
um where what i'm gonna do is uh give a
vertex
per junction
and uh i'll have an undirected edge
for each pipe
whose weight is the length
okay by the way i think the length i
didn't even mention in the problem
description but i believe
she wants to find the shortest path that
maximizes the
radius so like if they're like multiple
different paths that she could take that
both have the same radius and the
sensors
then she'd like to be lazy and not walk
too far so that's that's where this is
going to come into play
okay that's sort of a secondary concern
i would imagine on
atlas's behalf here okay
and moreover uh i'm not gonna even
attempt to
remember the the details of this problem
but but rather there's a source
which i'm sure has some cute hunger
games
uh name attached to it and some other
target um
these are just two nodes in the uh the
network of pipes and she wants a path
from s to t
okay so first of all uh let's just count
um and make sure that we know uh so
there's uh how many vertices are there
well the problem actually gives a name
to that there's order n
vertices because that's just the number
of junctions which is what we define to
be n
because i forgot to write that there uh
and because we have a degree bound
uh our favorite argument uh in this
class we know
that there's order n edges
as well so that's that's good news
why can't i use this graph directly like
let's say that i computed the shortest
path from s to t
notice that that completely ignores the
point of the problem right
the point of the problem is that uh
atlas wants to avoid these starred
vertices on our graph up here
but the shortest path may not do that in
other words you may have to walk like a
really indirect path
to avoid being detected by the sensors
that's a problem so we need to be a
little more clever than that
we do have to think on this problem a
bit okay but not too much
uh and so here's the basic trick like
let's say
that let's solve a slightly different
problem first which is let's say that i
give you a radius k
and i want to know does there exist a
path
that can get me from s to t without
coming more than distance k
away from the sensors
notice that once i if i have a tool that
can answer that like yes or no problem
i could come up with an algorithm that
that finds my number of sensors by like
looping over k or something it may not
be fast enough but
i could do that okay so that problem
is actually not terribly difficult
because essentially
what i could do conceptually is just
remove the vertices that are too close
to the sensors
and then solve a reachability problem
like can i get from s to t
without getting distance k away from any
one of the sensors
well what do i do i just remove any
vertex this distance k away from the
sensors and then i compute reachability
so conceptually i think this isn't a
huge leap intuitively
uh speaking but there's a lot of details
to fill in yeah
so unraveling just a little bit more
we might define a graph g k and g k
is going to be the sub graph
um a vertices whose distance
uh with a
distance bigger than k to
any sensor
right and somehow reachability in this
thing can answer
yes or no can i get from s to t without
coming you know distance k
uh to a sensor but do we know this term
sub graph in this class
essentially it's pretty clear what it is
just from the the word right like
sometimes i'm just going to remove
vertices uh that that
um inside of our larger graph and any
edges that touch those vertices
uh and obviously if my original graph
had order n size then the subgraph has
big o of n size might have less but but
this one has an upper bound
okay so we unravel a little bit more
somehow this seems like a convenient
structure but i haven't told you how to
compute it uh and in particular
uh the sort of annoying thing is uh
this piece right i need to be able to
figure out if i'm distance k
from any sensor or more generically
speaking it might be kind of handy
to compute distance from every
from the set of sensors to every other
vertex in my graph every other junction
in my pipe network
okay well we already covered a trick
uh in our problem sessions that's going
to help us do that right because
okay what would be a very simple
algorithm for doing that would be to
loop over every sensor
called dijkstra's algorithm for each one
right so that gives me the the distance
to sensor number one
and the distance to sensor number two
this is the sensor number three
and then i take the min over all those
and that function gives me the distance
to any sensor
that's going to be a problem right
because dijkstra's algorithm runs in n
log n time
but now i've incurred another factor
because i have to loop over all the
sensors
and we didn't give you a bound on how
many there are
so more generically this is actually a
problem that shows up all the time uh in
my everyday life
which is that like we don't just want
compute the shortest path to a single
point sometimes one shortest path to a
bunch of stuff
like in other words i don't care which
sensor is close to me i don't want to
get close to
any sensor yeah uh this shows up in
geometry all the time like maybe i want
to know the
closest you know like i want to find the
closest point on the highway you know so
the highway is driving past
uh my house so the highway is a whole
bunch of points on some network
and i just want to get on the highway
and start driving um
i don't care about the closest path to
every single point on the highway i just
want the
whatever is closest to me right so this
is a pretty practical thing to think
about
so how do we solve that so let's say
this is our pipe
network i feel like i draw this network
a lot
maybe i'll spice it up with an extra
edge
okay and maybe uh for board drawing
purposes
these two vertices have sensors
so i'm trying to find the shortest path
distance
to either one of these two vertices
from every other vertex on the graph or
vice versa that doesn't matter it's
undirected
and i don't want to loop over all these
sensors that's the basic headache here
so one thing that i can do is it's kind
of a sneaky trick and it's exactly the
same trick that we've applied a few
times in the problem sessions here
is to add a new vertex
that's kind of like a source and make
that vertex
distance zero to every one of my sensors
and now what i'm gonna do is do single
source shortest path
from this new extra vertex that i added
to all the rest of my graph
now why do i do that well if you think
about it well there's an edge of length
zero to any sense
sensor topologically i can think of it
like i glued all the sensors into one
vertex
if i wanted but that doesn't really
matter um
in fact that would be a different way to
solve this problem i guess would be to
take all the sensor vertices glue them
together into one and then solve this
problem but
i digress um right so
the shortest path distance from our new
source vertex to all the other ones
is going to be just the shortest path to
any sensor because notice
that any path coming out of s
necessarily has to pass through a start
vertex
okay so let's write that down basically
what i'm trying to do here is in step
one of my algorithm i want to label
each junction
with its distance to a sensor
right that's the high level goal here
and the way that i'm going to do that
is i'm going to make uh oops in in the
problem solution we call it x so i'll be
consistent uh i'm going to make a new
vertex or a new graph rather
g prime which is equal to my original
graph g
which is coming from the pipe network
with one extra vertex
which we're going to call x which is
connected to every motion sensor
uh
with weight zero
okay and now i'm going to do dijkstra
starting at
x
uh which takes n log n time
because i just gave you the size of our
graph up here and gives me
essentially the shortest distance to any
motion sensor
from all the vertices in my graph so
that's a good thing that's sort of like
a convenient
piece of information but when we're
solving these kinds of algorithms
problems notice that i've done
sort of a similar reasoning in both of
the last two problems
um which you can do and actually it's a
pretty practical way of thinking about
algorithms
where like this problem tells me at the
end of the day my algorithm has to run n
log n time
right or like in the previous problem i
had to run an n cube time
i guess v cube time
so one thing i can do is say what is all
the information that i can gather out of
my graph in n log n time and i might as
well compute it
right so for instance the distance to
the closest center uh sensor
i just gave you an n log n algorithm for
computing it it seems like a useful
piece of information so what the heck i
might as well compute it in step one and
just have it around
um obviously you could do breadth first
search on all the computable numbers and
this might not be
the most efficient way to solve a
problem but i think for graphs there's
only so many things that we typically
want to compute so it's worth kind of
going down your checklist
like similarly here notice that like we
gave you a budget of v
cube time so like you might as well
compute all pairs shortest path because
we can do it if you keep time then why
not have that information around seems
useful for
computing radius okay so in any event
now in step one we now know how uh close
every junction is to every sensor so
now i can argue i'm numbering these like
steps but they're not really steps these
are more just like
thought bubbles so thought bubble number
two
is going to be how do i actually
construct gk
right and notice i have a nice piece of
information here i now know
what vertices are inside of gk and which
ones aren't right because i can just
loop over all the vertices if the
distance is bigger than k
i keep it if it's not i don't yeah so
that gives me an algorithm for computing
um gk so we can construct
construct starts with a c construct
g k from our original graph g
and that's really easy to do right just
by
looping over the vertices
and remove
any whose distance is too big or too
small rather
v that makes sense because those are the
ones that are
dangerous if like the radius of my
sensor is k
any vertex with this is less than or
equal to k i want to throw away
um and how much time does this take well
there's just a loop over the vertices
i guess i need to account for the
storage of my graph also but of course
this graph takes less space than g and
so overall
this takes order and time
tim time and space
but there's a catch which is this is per
k okay so every time i want to make a
new g
uh a new gk i incur an expensive order n
but this is already getting us pretty
close to our problem
because what can we do if i have gk i
can say that
bffs on
gk establishes
reachability
from s to t
right which is what we care about um
outside of radius k
and how much time does bfs take
linear the size of the graph i only ever
asked jason one question which is so you
know
always has the same answer um right so
bfs takes time linear in the size of our
graph
our graph has size n or kind of 2n ish
so at the end of the day this takes
order m
so if our problem were written slightly
differently we would be done
right if the problem said you know given
a radius k
and a graph you know tell me yes or no
does there exist a path that
stays outside of radius k of the sensors
this is how we would do that
hopefully we all agree and we can do
that in order n time
oh just kidding order n log n time
because i had to do uh dijkstra's
algorithm first
thanks okay uh but uh sadly for us we're
we're not quite done because we want to
find the largest uh possible
k we wanted to find the biggest radius
that we can stay away from the sensors
uh and still get successfully from s to
t
so let's say that i uh want to find this
number so this is
going to define k star like at a moving
target to write on
is the largest
k where g
k is connected
well that's not quite right from
s to t this is a weird way to phrase it
really this
should say where there exists a path
from s to t and g k i'm sorry
we uh yeah where g k
i've just phrased this in a funny way
[Laughter]
has path from s to t
there we go all right
so our question is how do we find that
well here's a dumb algorithm
i could loop over all k's
construct gk and then if my answer is
yes it's reachable
then go to the next k increment by one
and start over
right so this is the dumb answer uh
when i say dumb i mean the answer that
your instructor wrote down on his notes
and then realized what's done okay which
is
loop over k
until you get to k star i guess plus 1
right because once i get there then i
get a thumbs down
obviously getting any bigger than that
is only going to make my graph smaller
this is called a filtration right
because each graph is contained inside
of
a different one um actually a filtration
would be the other way
i'll think about it for later because
this is not a topological data analysis
class
uh but in any event um if i did that how
much time will it take
well remember okay so for one thing i
have n log n from dijkstra's algorithm i
don't get around that
so i always have to account for that
but now every time i try a new k
i incur cost n right that's what we
argued up here
and so at the end of the day this
algorithm takes order
k star and time like that
of course it's a little weird to have
the answer of your problem in the run
time
but k star here it could be we don't
have any bound here it could be
the number of vertices or anything like
that yeah
and so if we have a budget of n log n
time this doesn't
quite work and so the question is can we
rescue this uh this strategy here
and the answer of course is yes or else
i wouldn't be standing here today
uh one way that you might do that so
there's the
way that you would do that as a real
algorithms person then there's a way you
could do it by psychologically
diagnosing your instructors
let's let's talk about both of those um
let's actually do the second one first
because i think that's the most
practical if you want to get your
homework done quickly
um which is as follows this problem
tells you that you have an analog and
budget of time uh in order to run the
algorithm
and so what does that mean well when we
loop
over potential gks that we can try we
have a budget
of log n tries before we're done
yeah uh so we kind of know that any
algorithm that constructs a gk and tries
it can only do it log n times
and to my knowledge we only have one
algorithm that runs in login time in
this class
which is binary search and so we might
be thinking very critically about how we
could use that tool
but more generally than that i think
this is actually a strategy that shows
up a lot both in algorithms and actually
numerical analysis a lot
uh which is you have some like yes or no
answer
and you want to find like the point on
the interface right but where yes flips
to know
and so one way to do it is to sort of
bound it on two ends
then keep dividing in half and as long
as your relationship is a bunch of yeses
and then a bunch of no's
you can keep doing that by binary search
right so so let's think about it this
way so like we have a long
interval of k values
by the way obviously there's an upper
bound here which is like the biggest
distance to any vertex in my graph or
something like that
yeah like the sum of all distances or
some different
very large numbers
but you can afford a lot you could if
you took the sum of every edge
here's a way to do it if you if you took
this to be the sum of every possible
edge length
um polynomial polynomially bounded
difference between u and n
[Music]
but that's okay um in any of it let's
say that we have an upper bound for k
for now
then what do we know we know that here's
like the k
star that i want and to the left
my algorithm will return yes this
algorithm up here up here it'll say
no right so one thing i can do
one thing i should do is put k star not
right at the end center of my interval
um for illustration purposes
but now i can binary search right
because i could query here and now i'm
going to get it no
and maybe i subdivide that's the
midpoint for some reason now i get a yes
and i can kind of triangulate in on what
i want
right so that's our basic strategy is
binary search here
um but we have to figure out
how to do that exactly okay
so first of all um okay there is an
obvious upper bound here which is just
the biggest distance from any vertex to
any sensor
yeah uh right so we could probably come
up with a conservative one we didn't
feel like it but
um conveniently in step one remember
that computing convenient numbers is
always a convenient thing to do
um clearly if katniss wants to sorry
sorry atness wants to go within a radius
that's bigger than the distance
of any vertex to any sensor she's in
trouble because like that covers the
entire graph
yeah so um right so we actually do have
an
upper bound here which is the biggest
distance to a sensor
and now we want a binary search but be a
little bit careful how to do it
because we want to be logarithmic and n
which is like the number of vertices in
our graph
and of course the way that i've drawn
this interval here
as jason points out i i don't at least
immediately have a bound
on this number in terms of n right like
it could be that my edge weights are
like really ginormous
uh okay so uh right
so how can we get around that well
essentially what we want to be doing is
binary search in an array that scales
like the vertices
okay uh and here's the the solution that
i came up with which i'm pretty sure is
the same as one in the answer i should
really check that before
teaching this thing uh which is to do
the following
which is a remember like again
we have a budget at n log n and so we
can do a constant number of things that
take n log n time we just might as well
keep doing it
yeah and so another kind of convenient
thing we might do
is sort my vertices
by the distance
to x which of course remember is exactly
the distance to their closest sensor
why would you do that well in some sense
like as i move along that array
that's the sort of order in which i'm
going to remove vertices from my graph
and make the radius get bigger and
bigger and bigger does that make sense
because like these you know the first
couple ones the ones right next to the
sensor
as i move along this array uh they get
farther and farther away
okay so we're going to say and of course
why can we do that because sorting
i think this is one that all computer
science students everywhere know takes n
log n time
using whatever your favorite sorting
well that's not true whatever my
favorite sorting algorithm is
okay and we're going to take d i to be
the distance the ith largest
i actually think in my notes i got this
one the i is smallest
i'm diverting from my notes so there is
a high likelihood of a sign mistake
that's about to happen
okay and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to binary search
on i in other words on the index into my
distance array
there's a reason to do that is there a
like let's say that my distances are
like one
two five seven right so these are the
distance of some vertex
to a sensor and let's say that i test
three
and i notice that three is admissible
you know in other words she can get from
one vertex to another um
never getting within a radius of three
should i try a radius of four
well no because i'm going to remove
vertices only when i pass
an element in this array right so it
makes sense to do binary search not in
distance space
but rather in array index space because
those are the sort of place junctures
that determine
when i'm going to remove stuff okay
so uh right so remember how big is this
array it's got length
n so overall this binary search takes
log n time and that's good
because our whole algorithm now what do
we do
we binary search on d or rather we bind
our search on i
and then we take d i and plug it into
our algorithm up there to construct our
sub graph
we test yes or no and that tells us the
left or the right interval in our binary
search and and we recurs
uh and so overall uh this takes log n
time
but uh or rather log n
steps of
binary search and of course each one of
these steps as i argued up there takes
order n
time so overall our algorithm takes
order
n log oh no i made an accidental theta
and log n uh time and that was the bound
we wanted uh
to achieve as usual there's like a lot
of detritus that we need to clean up at
the end of our problem here one of them
is that we actually want to return a
path
but that's not so bad right so now we
we've essentially determined that
we can compute k star in n log n time
well that's good it says now we actually
want the path
we can construct our graph one more time
right at k-star i suppose we already
have it around from the end of binary
search
uh and then use whatever your favorite
reachability algorithm is
uh to go from s to t uh and and give
katniss the path that she wants
or specifically dijkstra's algorithm if
you want the shortest path um
which is courteous because she doesn't
want to walk too far she doesn't have to
uh moreover uh let's see there are a
couple boundary cases that are probably
worth mentioning in your problem so for
instance
if k star equals zero in other words i
do my binary search i get all the way
back to the first element of my array
and it's still saying
i can't do it what does that mean that
means that i cannot
go from my source to my target node
without passing through a vertex that
has a sensor at it
yep uh and in which case what do you do
well you can return
any path or you might as well return the
shortest path so that she can run
[Laughter]
okay uh and that i believe uh uh
concludes our problem
any questions about that one thumbs up
cool how are we doing on time as usual i
think i'm gonna end early
and we're precisely the same time i've
always had a problem for
okay so problem four we move from one
fictional universe to another here
so now we're playing like okay pawn or
something like that
[Applause]
sorry if i didn't write so big i
wouldn't have to waste half of class
erasing
but that's okay
right so
cool so now we have ashley get him
and ashley gidham is trying to go from
twinkle town to blue blue bluff
and uh these are both two clearings in
the tanko region i'm sure if i played
pokemon this would have meaning to me
uh or whatever this is uh but in any
event
we have a bunch of math and we have a
map of a bunch of clearings
not liking the erasing on this board so
maybe we'll start
up here
okay so we have n clearings
uh and they're connected by two
way trails
uh and thankfully there's less than or
equal to five trails connecting in every
clearing
this is like our favorite detail to add
to six double h6 problems is a degree
bound yep
okay now with every trail
we associate um
a length um
[Music]
which we're going to call l sub t for
trail t
but in addition to that we're going to
have another piece of information
which is that it has a set of critters
on a c sub t right so
now every trail you know our our
character here is walking along the path
and what does she want to do anytime
that she
walks along a path she collects a
critter
or however many critters are on that
path in fact
she feels a very similar way to how i
feel at t.j maxx right
she's walking down the aisles and like
she can't help herself she's got to
catch every
critter that she goes past on the path
there's there's no option here she can't
leave it behind
because if she does then she'll be sad
and the way the reason why our character
might not be able to pick up
uh one of the critters would be if she
ran out of her tools for picking up
these critters which are apparently
pocket spheres
and she has uh k spheres
in other words she has like a backpack
and the backpack can hold that many
spheres at a time
okay uh there are a few uh details here
one is that every time she walks down a
path she collects all the critters
but then if she walks down that path
again she'll collect the same set of
critters apparently they they respawn
they're very
prolific these these critters uh and
moreover
uh there are stores
at some of the clearings
and at these stores she can get rid of
the critters she currently has and drop
them off and pick up
uh empty uh spheres instead right so
essentially every time she does that she
empties her backpack
and gets a new set of material where she
can keep picking up the critters
i have many questions about this
character like does she just leave them
there does she come back
for them later what does she do with the
critters
there's a lot of questions like did she
have a bigger bag she can go back around
to the stores
but in this fictional universe we're not
going to worry about these problems
okay and so um right so essentially the
question here
is that there are two uh uh
locations i don't remember the name
trundle trown to blue bluff that she's
trying to travel in between
and she gets sad if she
comes across a critter that she can't
collect so the question is
can you find the shortest
path without
being sad
and in like kind of a dada twist in this
problem
uh if no such path exists in other words
it's like
she has to walk along some long trail
with a bunch of critters
more than k critters i guess in the
worst case then sadness is unavoidable
is what your code is apparently
supposed to uh return which is really
defeatist i don't know who wrote this
problem set
um okay so the question is how do we
how do we solve this it looks like a
shortest path problem but as with all
problems in six stabilistics
there's a slight twist right in this
case the twist
is that it's the shortest path without
becoming sad where
sadness means that you ran out of
spheres to collect
your critters
now notice that we're given a budget by
the way
of i believe n k log n k times is that
right
like that okay
notice that this is a little suspicious
somehow it makes us think that the size
of our problem really is
nk rather than just n or k
okay so uh how could we do this
let's think back to a problem that we
solved yesterday under the assumption
that you guys are binge watching your
606 problem sessions here uh
and remember the problem yesterday we
had this dude that was walking along
paths and like
every third path he had to drink a beer
i've tried this on my commute home and
it doesn't doesn't work terribly well
uh but in any event we have kind of a
similar scenario here
where like there's some number that we
need to keep track of right the in this
case is the number of critters that our
our character has
uh remaining that she can pick up right
so she starts with an empty bag
as she collects them the amount of
capacity in her bag decreases
until she gets to a store and then it
goes back again but the good news is
that our runtime bound includes k
in it so it's actually okay to make an
algorithm that scales
in the number of critters that she can
carry around that's kind of a typical
but but
an interesting choice here okay
so remember the the term i introduced
last time for this kind of universe is
that it's called a state machine
like in addition to walking along the
graph she needs to know how much
capacity she has
for critters uh and so here's here's a
way to do it so i think
actually this problem isn't too bad
given that you saw the problem where you
do every third vertex uh in our last
problem session somehow it's just like a
same church different pew kind of
scenario here
so in this case uh one thing we can do
is we're going to make a graph
we're going to call him g he's got
vertices v
edges e just for fun
but what we're going to do is have k
plus
1 vertices
for every clearing
and the reason is that what we're going
to do is we're going to walk along the
graph
and as we traverse our edges we're not
only going to keep track of the costs
like the distance that she's walking
but also the number of critters that she
has remaining in her bag that she can
store and the way that we can do that
is by like keeping a bunch of copies of
our graph and ascending
every time that we collect a new crater
that makes sense
okay so here's a let's add a little bit
more detail here so in particular i can
define
v c comma i is going to be the
vertex per clearing comma creator space
uh and and the way that i can view it is
that this is um
sort of representing that i'm at
clearing
oops this should be a c
and i have
i pocket spheres
uh that are empty
okay so like initially i'm gonna start
at
v s comma zero and go from there okay
okay oh i guess it depends whether
you're decreasing it or increasing it
oh you're right yeah i'm sorry so in
that case i guess it would be k
we'll see if i managed to do that
consistently throughout my answer here
um okay so now i need to tell you how to
make the
the edges in our graph and so let's do
that next so in particular
for all trails
from a uh between a and b
with length
l um and critter c
right so she picks up c critters she
traverses
distance l she gets from a to b or vice
versa
and our trails are our bi-directional
here
uh we need to define edges
and they look like this so we sort of
have two different cases uh one
uh is where you have a store and one is
when you don't
right because that that's going to
affect how your state changes
so
right so the first one would be uh
oh did i get this whole thing backward
oh don't tell me that
no i didn't okay good um great so
the first case would be a does not have
have a store um
right so in this case she leaves with
the same number of critters she had in
her bag
minus whatever critter she picks up
along the way right so now
i'm going to have a an
edge of
length l
uh and i'm going to go from
v a comma i
to v
b comma i minus c right so the idea is
that i go from
a to b and in the process i lose c
critters
right but i have to do this for all the
possible i's that i could see in my
state
so that goes from ct
oops to k
right it's c
associated with the trail t which i
decided not to use
okay uh right so the basic point here is
that
there are a bunch of different states
where i can traverse this trail but i
have to have at least c
critters in my bag if i'm allowed to
traverse this trail or else i will be
sad
okay and so i kind of copy this edge a
bunch of different times to represent
all the possible transitions i could
make
and similarly let's say that a does have
a store
well i still want to add an edge but now
i have the luxury
of clearing out all the stuff in my bag
before collecting the critters
yeah so now uh i still want an edge of
length
l um but now i get to
connect more vertices and reset my state
in the process right so now i'm going to
go from
v a comma i to
v b
and where am i going to end up
well how many critters are going to be
in my bag i have a bag of capacity k
and i just reversed the edge from a to b
which contains c critters
so
i get in v k minus c like that uh
and of course um i can do that for for
all i
uh from
oh yeah i have to be careful
well no actually just for all eyes fine
yeah i think there might be
a there's either a mistake in how i
copied it down or a mistake in the
problem
i'm mistaking the problem
yeah i think this is right yeah so i
think there's we wrote for all i in some
interval but we didn't have to
okay right so uh those are our different
cases right so essentially in this case
we we we clear out our our q
here our well not even a q just our set
of
spheres we reset we go back here notice
that the second vertex doesn't even have
an i in its index because it doesn't
matter
okay and then similarly uh
you know so that gets me from a to b i
also have to do the symmetric thing to
go from b to a
okay so now i have a graph um
and first of all we should reason and
make sure that we can actually construct
this graph in a reasonable amount of
time
so let's do that really fast
right so uh the number of vertices in
our graph
well i basically have k plus one copies
of my graph so it's equal to
k plus 1 times n that's good so that's
order k
and order k and space
i suppose and similarly
there's k edges
um that are associated with every trail
and there's order n trails because i
have a degree bound so
overall there's order k and edges
in my graph okay
great so now uh my problem is not so bad
i have a
source uh which is the the place where
our walker starts
ft which is the destination where she
wants to go
um so what do i need well i just need
any path that starts at
v s k right in other words she starts at
s and has a full bag with k capacity
and ends up at to v
uh t comma i for any i
right because it doesn't matter how much
capacity she has in her bag when she
reads her
her destination so this is for all i
any path avoids
sadness in the way this problem is
written
right so how could i do that well she
wants the shortest path
um so i can just do dijkstra's algorithm
from v sk and do a bit of cleanup
afterward to check all the different
eyes and find this closest one
and how much time does that take well my
graph
takes k n space space because it has k
n vertices and order can edges
so overall this is going to take order k
n log k n
time which is a good thing because
that's exactly the problem asked for
and of course uh if the
shortest path is infinity
then what do we know if you say with me
sadness is unavoidable this is a weird
thing
to write on a blackboard
okay and so that's our basic problem
here so what was our strategy if we step
back 10 feet essentially we took our
graph
and rather than just making our graph we
make k copies of it with edges that kind
of point upstairs
uh meaning that you you you give away
spheres uh in the the process of
traversing these different edges
except when you hit the stores which
brings you back to level zero
um so that was our basic graph structure
and then we just need to do shortest
path on that thing
all right any questions about that yes
graph duplication we made a
it was layered graph and you kept making
these transitions
and it was a day so can't we do this in
linear time
can't we do this in linear time so in
other words why is our graph not a dag
in this particular case um
let me think about that for a second
there's nothing about this problem that
i mean that says that the graph has to
be a dag
uh in particular i guess you could keep
walking like if you had a path
with a store that were exactly the same
as the number of critters you could keep
walking
back and forth along that path um and so
it was like a little cycle there
which would be enough to not be able to
do it in linear time well the edges that
we constructed are not
are not don't necessarily correspond to
the edges in the original trails that's
not
the problem uh sure that's absolutely
right so
we constructed a directed graph out of
our original one
but that directed graph also can contain
cycles right um
so yeah so i think the example i'm
giving you works so i have a graph
with two vertices maybe there's other
graph stuff going on but whatever i have
two vertices here
and i have some number of critters here
and i have a store
on either end of my edge just because
i'm boring and conservative
and now well assuming that c is less
than k
i can just keep going back and forth
along this edge as many times i want
and this is for free right because every
time i get to the end of the edge i
throw all my critters away
so that's an example of a cycle in my
graph and because there's a cycle
i'm not in the dag case anymore it's a
cycle in the constructed ground
sorry yeah it is a cycle here and also a
cycle in the constructed graph
um yeah sorry i guess
that's true all right any other
questions i can make a hash of here
excellent so am i out of time ah shucks
no
um okay in that case we'll do the last
problem here
actually last problem i think is the
most interesting one so as usual i've
left myself with not enough time
okay which of these boards is the
tidiest
the answer is none of yeah none of the
above so let's use the backs here
um okay
right so our last problem is a uh
shipping problem
not a trans shipment problem which
happens to be my area of research but
rather
uh just a a good old shipping thing so
here
um strangely
i did not give myself my complete notes
so this will be fun um
right so i'm trying to ship servers from
san francisco to cambridge by truck
and i have all these bunch of
third-party companies that all have
pairs of cities that they can ship
between and only so much these companies
are kind of divas they have a weight
limit they only have like cities
they're directed edges i can't like they
don't drive their trucks back apparently
or maybe they like pick up somebody
else's stuff and they're just picking
your stuff up in the
boring direction or whatever uh so i
have a bunch of
i have n trucking roots
and each root r sub i
is a tuple with s i t i w
i c i and what are all these things so
here
uh this is the source
of uh every shipping route every
trucking route here
this is the target right so this is like
where the truck starts this is where the
truck ends
this is the max weight
that the truck can handle so like the
truck only has so much space in it
you know the tires are only so big
and if i put something of white bigger
than w uh then my my truck is is going
to die so that's the most that i can put
on this truck
and this is the cost okay
and i have a n routes that look like
this and i'm trying to ship servers and
of course some of my
servers are too darn busy but we make an
assumption here which is that our
trucking routes form a uh
sort of a continuous network i can get
from s to t and ship at the very least
like a pencil eraser you know like some
minimal amount of weight
okay and so the basic uh
end point of this problem is going to be
uh to sort of figure out the heaviest
thing that i can
ship uh and and uh we we give you a
problem on the uh
sort of on the path toward that uh to
help prove a little bit about this
this is a very typical kind of setup
so again i've got a bunch of trucking
routes each one of which has a max
weight
and i'm going to want to know first of
all what's the maximum amount of weight
i can
ship and then what is the minimum cost i
can ship that that weight
so in problem a which is marked as
useful digression
um we're first going to prove kind of a
handy uh inequality
i decided to go off book with my proof
ever so slightly of this so get excited
uh for this to be slightly
uh wrong in a subtle way which is what i
specialize in
um but in particular uh we're gonna make
a definition here so
let's say that pi is a weighted
path okay then
the bottleneck of pi
of pi is going to be the
the minimum edge weight
of of any edge in in pi
and to make sure that we see how this is
connected to the problem um you know if
i'm trying to ship a server and i have
to put on truck one and truck two and
truck three and truck four and truck
five
um obviously of those five trucks the
one whose capacity
uh for weight is the smallest is the
only one that matters in terms of the
heaviest thing that i could ship
okay so uh right now uh given
two given a directed graph and two
vertices s and t
we're going to define a quantity called
b of s comma t
and we're going to say that this is the
max
over any path pi from
s to t of the bottleneck
of pi okay so so the sanity check this
quantity here
essentially what it's saying is at the
end of the day i have this big network
of trucking routes
i just want to go from one city to
another and i don't care which series of
trucks i want to use i just want to
maximize the
weight that i could ship right and so
this is saying i'm going to look at
all the different paths that i could
take
each path is sort of band limited by the
one truck that has the lightest weight
that it can carry
um and i'm gonna find the path that has
the best
bottleneck as measured by this quantity
using the word best because i
tend to make signed mistakes and that's
a vague term okay
and then uh right uh
so
writing too big hopefully i won't run
out of space
we're gonna make one additional uh
definition which is i
of t is the incoming
neighbors of
t okay and then the problem is asking
you to prove
a particular inequality here
claim which is that b of s
t is bigger than or equal to um
the min of two values b
of s v
or w of v
t for all
uh v in i of t
so let's see what this is saying so
remember that this is like the capacity
that i can ship from s to t using any
root
um and that that upper bounds uh the
minimum of two things right either
the capacity of shipping to one of my
neighbors with an
incoming edge or the weight
of basically shipping from that neighbor
to me notice this is kind of similar to
a triangle inequality
which is why we're going to kind of know
how to solve part b of this problem
pretty easily
okay
and moreover with
equality
for some
v star in i of t
okay guess what that v star is going to
be it's going to be
the vertex that's sort of the previous
one on the path of
of of trucks that i actually take to
ship stuff
right okay so how can we prove this so
the intuition here is that the path
that's actually giving you this
bottleneck this b s comma t
has to include one of my incoming edges
and i'm just trying to find it right
that's roughly what's what's going on in
this inequality
and and by the way whenever a problem
asks you to prove an inequality you
should step back
you know like i feel like i spend like
85 percent of my day with research
students sort of saying like okay well
like what is it really telling me about
life and and this is a good
example okay so to that end
um i'm going to make a definition which
i found to be convenient when i was
solving this problem
which is the following i'm going to say
that pi
s comma t is going to be the actual
path uh that gives me the bottleneck so
this is kind of like the
arg max over
all pi you can use really bad notation
and pi is
connect s to t that's how we're going to
think of that
of the bottleneck
so in other words like this
is the path that actually realizes
this quantity b right so in other words
b of s
t is equal to bottleneck
pi only has two lines that's two this is
convenient for me because the reasoning
about that path
uh makes some sense um okay
so now um we're gonna prove the
inequality first and then
we may or may not choose to prove the
equality case depending on
how i feel okay so uh right so let's
section this off
and try and use my board a little more
conservatively here
uh okay so
right so now let's take
a vertex v from the incoming
uh edges here of t
right because that's what we need to to
prove this and we're just going to prove
the
inequality directly here in particular
um we can define
a path that goes from s to t as follows
i could take the uh pi
s v and then concatenate onto the end of
this guy
um t
right because we know that there's a
directed edge from v to t by definition
of what this i
is okay um
right and so this is kind of convenient
because this is like the bottleneck path
for
one of my neighbors and now i'm just
kind of sticking an edge on there and we
know
uh that of course this is a candidate
path to get from s to t
but it may not be the one that actually
achieves the bottleneck
okay right so uh
yeah uh and let's uh oops let's define
that to be pi
uh twiddle just for for fun i like to
give things names
okay so what do we know we know
that b of s comma t
well this by definition is the max
bottleneck
of any incoming path going from s to t
this is a path from s to t
yeah so because this is the max it is
bigger than or equal to bottleneck
of pi twiddle right that's the nice
thing about maxes
they tend to be bigger than other stuff
okay
well what is the bottleneck of pie
twiddle well remember
our definition of bottle bottleneck here
right it's the
min edge weight over my entire path
well i have two options either that edge
weight is the edge from v to t
or it's the edge weight that's
associated to
the rest of this stuff yeah so either
this is the min of the
bottleneck
of the first segment of our path pi sv
by the way that may be empty and that's
like okay that's just like a one edge
path you can dispense with that case
pretty easily
uh or the weight of v
t cool
well by definition bottleneck of pi
sv is exactly this quantity right
because that's what i chose it to be
over here
yeah so this is exactly men
the b s comma v that was
supposed to be v but i wrote a t or
w of v comma t
and that is exactly what we wanted to
prove
yeah so that takes care of our
inequality case
do i want to do the equality case i
don't think i do
yeah so it's not too hard to check the
equality case essentially
you can you can make a pretty easy
contradiction right because if it's
strictly larger
then what does that mean that means
every single incoming edge
none of them can be the edge where your
bottleneck path comes in and obviously
there's something wrong with that
uh okay so i'll refer you guys to the
the notes for that one
and finally the problem says uh
assuming that uh
so now we have kind of a funny constant
in here just to make your life a little
bit annoying
we have on at most
three square root and cities
that we care about um again why
three why not uh i think and what we
want
is the weight of the single uh largest
server
and the minimum cost to ship uh that
thing so we want
one the largest weight we can ship
we'll call that w star to ship
and two is the smallest
cost to ship
that weight w star okay
so let's do two first because it's easy
so let's say that i was able to compute
w star
so now what can i do well i can
construct a graph
where i only keep around the the trucks
that
can ship at most at least this amount of
weight
because the other ships are i really
want them to be boats in this problem
but the the other trucks uh are useless
right if they can't cover
w star then they're not pulling their
weight yeah so to do
part two here what can i do
i can make a new graph g sub c
with a vertex
for every city and
um an uh
right and an edge
a directed edge sorry
per shipping route
with um
[Music]
this is going to be an unfortunate clash
in terminology i'm going to say
edge weight to refer to the edge weight
in my graph
and that's going to be equal to the cost
of the edge um
and only keep around
but only for roots
that can carry at least um
w star amount of weight
and now what do we do well it's the
shortest path right at this point
um you know shortest path which is
really the minimum cost in this case
because that's what we're associating to
the edges
is going to give me the cost of shipping
w star in my network i think that's
pretty obvious from this construction
um so that's dijkstra
d-i-j-k-s-t-r-a
and now the only question is how much
time does it take so let's say that i do
the brain dead version of dijkstra where
i just use a direct access array to do
my priority queue
so if you recall that'll take big o of
mod v cubed here
squared squared yep you're right sorry
i was thinking johnson's algorithm okay
well in this case how big is v well
it's square root of n three times square
root of n
at most so of course v squared uh is
really
big o of n uh and
and the that part is solved yeah so
really
our only uh remaining problem here is to
do part one
and i don't have nearly enough time in
fact i'm completely out of time so maybe
we'll
just talk through it really briefly
sorry about that
um essentially the basic observation
here
is that the inequality that we proved in
part a of our problem
it's kind of like the triangle and
equality of the bottleneck world
in some sense um essentially what it's
giving you is
some or you know update formula that
looks kind of like the update formula
that we'd apply in dijkstra's algorithm
for shortest path
right the basic assumption here being
that well my shortest path has to come
from somewhere
right so if i look over all my neighbors
and then i kind of add in my closest
edge uh or rather you know the sum of
the
path length to the previous vertex plus
the edge to me because
the shortest path to me here instead of
that we're saying the biggest bottleneck
path so what do i do i look at all of my
incoming neighbors i find the one with
the biggest bottleneck
which is band limited by their
bottleneck plus the bottleneck of the
incoming edge
and then i update myself the only thing
remaining here
is to basically do exactly dijkstra's
algorithm
but rather than updating by summing edge
length we update by using this formula
and essentially everything else remains
the same
so conveniently i've run out of time so
i won't even have to
uh jumble this one on the board i'll let
you guys through that one at home
but i actually think the explanation of
the written material is pretty
self-evident for this problem so
that's probably just as well